so uh when you decided to do this
uh did you already have like pete and
becky g and megan in mind for roles in
this film
yeah yeah
yeah that none of them ended up playing
the roles that we planned
more awesome yeah i think was pete gonna
be the lead yeah pete was there yeah
like it's like we put all the names in
a bucket and shook it and then they came
out differently so
does pete know that he was once
considered for the lead and wound up for
the as the valet yeah first trick
[Laughter]
that's funny that's really funny
still the lead candidate
no i was just gonna say uh there's a
great sort of montage uh with you
coulson where you're putting you're
doing self tapes and i'm wondering if
before this had you already worked on
your potter and malfoy
you know what's crazy
no like that was we we had i actually
the only thing in the script that was
written was self tape and then there was
that that we had listed like 10
impressions but almost like beyonce yeah
one was like beyonce and single ladies
it was just like it was all these things
that i've never done i'm not even like
an impersonator or someone who does
those and so when we set it up i took
like four tequila shots and was like
i'm really intimidated by this like idea
that i have to do things that i've never
done so i yeah
the the clip that made this the movie
was the first time i've ever even tried
harry potter or malfoy and that joke
like where's the pot potter
that wasn't that was he didn't tell
anyone what he was about to do
you didn't tell it you had these little
props on set yeah and i was like what
the what are you about to do i don't
know if i can swear what the okay what
you're about to do um
yo i was mad surprised when you did by
the way great job
great job i did not think you were going
to nail that nice yeah i think that was
the vibe we no one was i we me too i was
like
i don't think i can do this scene now
that we're all set up and all the people
are here the pressure's there
i don't think i'm the one to do the
impersonations
uh i have to know because you guys are
so tight and you're really the the two
most famous fiances in the world right
now have you guys had a conversation
where you make sure that stuff doesn't
go down on the same weekend like have
you at least had those conversations
where you don't both book the same
weekend
like i just proposed the week his like
album comes out or something like that
no like for the weddings for the
weddings oh good call joint wedding
real best friends though
i didn't think about that i didn't think
about that i even i just i just learned
that you were supposed to do an
engagement party from him because i
didn't do one i went to his engagement i
just learned that too yeah
i like went back home i was like babe i
think
were we supposed to do one of these like
i just want some mods
i was cracking over there i had friends
all these different food i felt like i
was in france i felt like we had a
yeah
are
wedding
are you each going to play each other's
bachelor parties
that's cool
i forgot you even do a bachelor party
yeah man bro you got to read a book
there's books because i'm not i'm
definitely not into the whole like
whatever i am familiar with a typical
bachelor party that's not my vibe you
know like that doesn't have to be vegas
in a limo yeah yeah i don't that's i
like i love my girl i don't want to be
around like
i'm down to like
i didn't say are you gonna have his back
if he cheats before the wedding i'm just
like you can get together with friends
have fun
and uh any chance that this could then
become a series this movie because it
really sort of has that vibe
just say it
this is the last time
never doing it again never doing it
again
ever we'll never work with this matagot
no you guys are great i really
appreciate your time thank you so much